starting off this hour is gonna be Jared
in California
Merry Christmas Jared how are you Merry
Christmas Dave I'm doing great how about
yourself
better than I deserve how can I help so
the reason for my call is uh me and my
wife did your Financial Peace University
a couple of years ago it's been
life-changing for us we're onto baby
steps four through six now and we're
starting to save up for our next
automobile purchase which we hope to do
with cash of course
my question for you is that cash that
I'm saving for the new car
should I keep that liquid with my
emergency fund or should I be investing
that in my mutual fund portfolio so that
it grows faster and I can reach my goal
sooner well if you're investing it for
less than five years you take the chance
of it going down as much as you take the
chance of it going up in a mutual fund
mutual funds okay you know generally if
you remember from Financial Peace
University ninety-seven percent of the
five-year periods have made money on the
stock market but only sixty seven
percent of the three-year periods have
so you have a one in three chance of
actually losing money when you're
playing with three years and I suspect
you're not saving very long for this car
right right it would be around the
five-year mark don't really I don't say
four five years for a car yeah right now
we're driving T sedans but we plan on
having more kids so at some point we're
gonna have to upgrade to a minivan or
something like that yeah cool okay so
how much would you be saving towards the
car um ideally twenty twenty to thirty K
okay over five years all right so let's
just take twenty K on five years as
$4,000 a year right yep and let's say
you made 10% on it versus one percent
that's a $400 swing per year okay so it
doesn't make or break the deal because
the actual dollars that you would make
during the period of time would be you
know if you made 10% for
is 1% as an example through the period
of time you might make 1,500 bucks or
something through the period of time but
it doesn't mean you get to buy a car
because of this or you don't get to buy
a car because you didn't put the money
in a mutual fund more in other words 98
99 percent of the money is going to be
you putting the money in the account
it's not going to be growth
mathematically and so the more you put
in the account the faster you're going
to get your van that's what it amounts
to and so you can do either one it's not
going to destroy you keep you from
getting a car if it went down in value
but it's more of a theoretical
discussion than it is an actual dollars
that move the needle and so that that's
sometimes what you can get caught up in
and in this personal finance game is all
these people have theoretical
discussions instead of exactly what
really happens hey thanks for the call
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five I'll give you an
example one of those theoretical
discussions okay you can do a Roth IRA
you can do a regular IRA and you can do
$6,000 a year if you're under fifty
years old okay now what happens is in
reality in the real world people just do
$6,000 in a traditional or they put
$6,000 in the Roth but of course there's
some tuber living and his mother's
basement writing a blog about our Dave
Ramsey doesn't understand mathematics
when he tells people to do that because
the when you actually look at the
mathematics of it according to the
doober in the basement he's actually
mathematically correct although I live
out here in the real world not in my
mother's basement but mathematically
what happens is in order to put the
money in order to put $6,000 in a Roth
you have to earn about $8,000 or $9,000
because you got to pay taxes the money
going into a Roth is an after-tax
calculation in order to put much $6,000
into a traditional you have to earn
$6,000 because it's pre-tax and so when
you compare a traditional with a Roth
you're technically comparing 9000 to
6,000 because it's an after-tax
investment if you wanted to do the
arithmetic
tick properly and do it in a vacuum
that's fine but here's the real world
the real world is people don't even
think like that they just put six
thousand dollars in and they just do it
and so you know the net result of me
getting everybody to do Roth says it's
as if they're investing nine ding ding
so you know I came out way ahead but you
know but I'm cheating of course because
people are getting rich faster and we
can't have that if you're a victim and
you live in your mother's basement so
there you go I mean but that's the in
the real world I mean math you haven't a
Ruth you have an arithmetic vacuum or a
theoretical discussion of mathematics
versus what people actually freaking do
and so if you'll start just kind of
thinking through what people are
actually freaking do then you've got a
deal another thing is everybody gets all
upset about some mutual funds charge of
Commission oh god you're gonna die if
you pay a commission to fees the fees
doesn't matter one of the largest
studies ever done by the actuarial
Association of America which is a group
of nerds found that 74% of the reason
that people end up building wealth in
their investments is not the fees it is
not the return on investment it's not
that they got 12.4 and the S&P was 11.8
it was not that you beat the S&P or
slightly didn't beat the SMP by a few
points here or half a point here they're
74% of the reason that people succeed in
investing is because they actually
invest it's called the savings rate
meaning you freaking put money into the
account instead of sitting around
sucking your thumb in the back booth of
some bar having some kind of a
discussion about mathematics I can't do
this the fees at Ramsey and the fees and
oh my god and oh Jesus and you can't
beat the S&P because everybody knows
passive investing and by the S&P because
real most mutual funds don't beat the
S&P buddy
Just In fast those are the people that
end up with money they're people that
put money into investments other people
have money in investments in that a
shocking statistical correlation I mean
it's amazing that this idea that
personal finance is really 80% behavior
it's only 20% head knowledge so I'm not
suggesting you overpay in fees and I'm
not suggesting you buy mutual funds that
underperform but really that's not the
secret the secret is for you to not get
paralysis of the analysis and analyze
everything to the point that you do
nothing do it just shut up and do it and
that's how people get rich isn't that
amazing the ones that actually do put
money and investments so the next time
your brother-in-law who's broke has a
theoretical discussion about investing
returns time all the Returns come from
Pete to people who put money in the
account